go ahead and update the save profile
method in conference API to save the
profile entity in the datastore you can
look for the place marked to do three in
the save profile method and that's where
you add the code to save the entity when
you've added the code go ahead and run
your app on localhost and then go to the
api's explorer and execute the save
profile method use the API Explorer to
try out the updated save profile
function you'll see the responses you
did before but you'll need to go to the
admin console to check that the profile
entity was saved in the datastore and
just a reminder to get to the admin
console on localhost you go to localhost
colon port number like localhost colon
8080 and then you type underscore a H
slash admin what properties does your
profile entity show in the in the admin
console check each one that applies